The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
J. KIM VANDIVER: We're
waiting for people to come in.
And what are the important
concepts this week?
There's only the one lecture,
and the lecture yesterday
was pretty dense in concepts.
Let's build a quick list here.
Who's got the first offering?
AUDIENCE: Rotational
dynamics of rigid bodies.
J. KIM VANDIVER: OK, that
was a general overall topic,
so how about a concept though.
AUDIENCE: The mass
moment of inertia matrix.
J. KIM VANDIVER: OK, yep,
we introduced the concept
of the mass moment
of inertia matrix.
And I'll give it a context,
so you can, for example,
write H as I times omega.
So we introduced that,
didn't get very far with it.
Another one from yesterday?
AUDIENCE: I'm not
sure if this fits
but talking about
how the body can
be rotating around the point
opposite the [INAUDIBLE].
J. KIM VANDIVER: Ah yeah.
Yep So we talked about rotation.
The subject yesterday was
really rigid body rotation
about fixed point
on or off the body.
So here's our axis of rotation.
Call it A. And it's spinning
about that point at some omega.
But that point A could
be over here too.
And then the whole
body is just going,
so an example of
rigid body rotation
about a point not on the body
would be something doing that.
OK, something else.
AUDIENCE: The angler
velocity [INAUDIBLE].
J. KIM VANDIVER: Yes.
Yeah, what does it means when
H and omega may not align?
What's that mean?
So we got into that
a bit yesterday.
And anything else
that struck you?
OK, well that's a good start.
Let's just work with that.
Now I will do that second.
We're going to come
work a little bit,
talking about this
system in those contexts.
Before I do that, I
want to-- the staff
decided we hadn't done something
in lecture yet very carefully
so we wanted to do it once
carefully within recitation.
And that's a methodical way
of doing free body diagrams.
So we have a system, two
masses, springs, dashpots.
In the last class,
there were a few people
who didn't know really what we
meant by k's and c's and how
they work.
So I will give you
a quick definition.
So here we have a spring.
And these are called linear
springs, so Hooke's law.
If you cause that
spring to move,
and I'll call it here the
plus x direction-- you grab it
and you pull on it-- you
have to apply a force.
So the force to pull that
spring is positive kx
in the same direction as x.
But if that spring's
attached to a mass what
direction is the force that
the spring applies on the mass?
So I've given you a hint here.
It pulls back, right?
Because this is
Newton's third law.
So we are doing
free body diagrams,
and we're concerned with
forces on the rigid bodies.
So, this spring, if
this mass went that way,
the spring would pull this way.
And we indicated the direction
with an arrow and its value
as a kx.
Dashpots are similar.
Except dashpots are
activated by velocity.
So this is a linear
dashpot, such that it
has a dashpot constant c.
And if I give this a
positive value of velocity,
the force required to pull
that dashpot is cx dot.
It's linearly proportional.
Velocity and the force that
if it were attached to a mass
that the dashpot
puts on the mass
would be opposite
direction but same value,
cx dot, but is
resisting the motion.
OK.
So I'm going to just
give you general method
for doing free body diagrams.
And the reason we
choose this problem is
there's two bodies,
and depending on which
is doing what, this
intermediate spring in here
particularly can push
or pull on either body
and having a method so you
don't mess up the signs
is what this is all about.
So let's just start by
building a free body
diagram of mass one.
And the assignment I'm going
to give you to work on,
just seat work
here for a minute,
is only consider
the springs for now.
We'll just deal
with the springs.
So assume the system is moving.
You have to do free
body diagrams of it.
Put the spring forces on
the mass in your free body
diagrams.
So spend a minute or so.
Talk to your neighbors after
you get a little ways along
with it.
And I'm going to
add-- there's also
on this whole system external
force F1, external force F2.
That's your excitation.
But don't worry
about that for now.
Just figure out the spring
forces, and I'll be quiet.
I missed a step, my apologies.
We should do
something else first.
The very first step is to
assign the coordinates.
Let's all agree on the
coordinate system here.
So the question really
is the first thing
you have to do is you have to
decide how many independent
coordinates you need to
completely describe the motion.
So how many coordinates
do you think
are needed for this problem?
I see a one.
AUDIENCE: I was just--
J. KIM VANDIVER:
That's a second one.
Anybody else have a suggestion?
So where would you put the one?
AUDIENCE: The x term.
J. KIM VANDIVER: And measuring
the displacement of mass one?
AUDIENCE: Sure.
J. KIM VANDIVER: OK.
And is that all we need?
Anybody have a further--
AUDIENCE: Oh, there's a
displacement at mass two.
J. KIM VANDIVER: And
it's independence, right?
They can move-- how
many coordinates now
do you think you need?
Uh oh.
She changed her mind to two.
And I've got them labeled
up here for you already.
So it's going to take two.
And one of the ways
you can test if you
have the right number, if you
think it's one, assign it.
Freeze it.
Is there still
independent movement
of a part of the system?
If there is, you have yet
another degree of freedom.
If we freeze both x1
and x2, and can anything
move in the system?
Nope.
So we've got it nailed down.
All right.
But where do you measure?
There is something else
you have to determine.
And that is, where
do you make zero?
You also have to know that.
So where is x is
0 in your picture?
We'll just talk about
both of them, x1 and x2.
How would you pick the 0 point?
Christina?
AUDIENCE: Probably
when the spring's
at equilibrium so when it's not
exerting force. [INAUDIBLE].
J. KIM VANDIVER: OK, she says
when there's not exerting
force in either direction.
I would call that the
static equilibrium position.
There is a conceptual
problem with that.
We'll assume that that
will work if you've
set the system up
so that there's
no forces in the springs.
But you know, if I move
this wall in a little bit
and let it reach
static equilibrium,
it has a static
equilibrium position.
All the springs
have forces in them.
Now, you pre-compress them.
So there's kind
of a problem-- you
could run into a conceptual
problem with that.
It will still work.
Picking a static
equilibrium position
is a good thing to do usually.
OK.
There are other positions.
For example, this system,
it's a simpler system, just
an ordinary little mass spring.
But where do you make zero
when you pick your coordinate?
AUDIENCE: In this case,
you could zero it out
at the rest length of the
spring plus the length
of this spring as a result
of the force of gravity.
J. KIM VANDIVER:
So right now you're
seeing the static
equilibrium position.
The spring has tension in it,
the weight of the mass, right?
So you could either
make x right here.
Or the other obvious
choice would be?
AUDIENCE: Where
you're holding it.
AUDIENCE: You're holding it.
J. KIM VANDIVER: I
heard a couple voice
but I couldn't
hear what you said.
AUDIENCE: Where
you're holding it?
J. KIM VANDIVER: Well,
yeah, but it turns out
that actually is
a terrible choice.
Because then you
have to get involved
with the length of the spring.
And the length of
the spring actually
really doesn't enter into
the equation in motion
unless you're really
silly about where
you pick the measure from.
Static equilibrium is
good, but the other one
is the zero spring
force position
is the other natural one to do.
So at zero spring force, that's
no extension of the spring.
Because this is preloaded when
you do this, and have to figure
out what that does to you.
OK.
Again, static equilibrium has
some real advantages here,
but we'll talk about that later.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So why does
zero spring force
work there but not--
J. KIM VANDIVER: I'm just saying
there are actually situations
where there is no zero force.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
J. KIM VANDIVER: And you have a
conception-- if you hadn't ever
thought of that before, that
could give you pause when
you go to solve the problem.
The springs are preloaded.
Are your equations
of motion valid?
So you preloaded
this a little bit,
squeezed it in, this system
has natural frequencies, right?
Do you agree with that?
It's very similar to this
system except it's just now--
it doesn't happen to
have a third spring
and have gravity involved.
But this system has two
natural frequencies,
that one and one that's
a little harder for me
to do but that one.
So if I've preloaded
this a little bit,
squeezed it in some, would the
natural frequencies change?
Yes-- how many think yes?
Get your hands up.
Come on.
You're gamblers.
How many think yes?
How many think no?
How many just don't want
to raise their hand?
[LAUGHS] Like you.
OK.
The natural frequency
doesn't change.
It turns out to
preload doesn't matter
in a linear system like this.
So there's some nuances in here.
A simple system like this
has some little traps in it.
It will take them time to
learn your way through.
But let's keep it simple.
No preload, the static
equilibrium position,
draw the free body diagram
for mass one, springs only.
Only deal with the springs.
Take a couple minutes
and talk to your neighbor
if you need to.
OK, so I won't come look
at each of your things.
I want to have different
groups kind of-- they
should take one force at a time.
So you guys, give me a force
on this mass, due to a spring.
Give me a spring force and
tell me what direction it's in.
AUDIENCE: I guess
it's [INAUDIBLE].
J. KIM VANDIVER: So tell
me which spring we're
talking about.
AUDIENCE: So
[? I didn't hear. ?] So is this
being impressed, like
are these springs?
J. KIM VANDIVER: No, this is
static equilibrium position.
But now if you give it initial
[INAUDIBLE] and let go,
it's going to sit
there and do something.
We're trying to derive
the equations of motion.
And to do so, we have to start
with a free body diagram.
So it's moving, and
there are forces
on it caused by
springs and by dashpots
and by the external forces.
So right now, we're going to
be free body diagram but only
the components
through the spring.
Springs.
So tell me what happens.
What does that spring--
how does this spring appear
on that free body diagram.
AUDIENCE: [? I have an idea. ?]
[INAUDIBLE] it's air force
is 11 [INAUDIBLE].
J. KIM VANDIVER: OK, force of.
AUDIENCE: Force of
the spring on the--
J. KIM VANDIVER:
Which direction?
AUDIENCE: Left. [LAUGHS] I don't
understand how you know which--
J. KIM VANDIVER:
OK, well that's kind
of the point of the exercise.
And I expect many of you to
have some confusion about what
direction to go because you
don't have a standard method
by which you approach this.
AUDIENCE: So both springs
and cause of force
goes in the direction
of the displacement.
J. KIM VANDIVER: OK, so what's
the displacement, though?
This system has two
possible displacements.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
We're assuming m1 is going in
the positive x1 [INAUDIBLE].
J. KIM VANDIVER: OK.
So if you said if you
move it a positive x1,
then you will get
a spring force.
Spring one does what?
AUDIENCE: It would
oppose the [? spring. ?]
J. KIM VANDIVER: Opposes,
and what's it value?
AUDIENCE: k1x.
J. KIM VANDIVER: k1x1.
So that's what a
motion x1 causes--
that's a result with spring one.
What's the result of spring
two if you have motion x1?
AUDIENCE: Same.
There's going to be
compression force that's
also opposing displacement.
J. KIM VANDIVER:
Right, because it's
trying to squeeze
that spring down,
and it's pushing back, right?
But you're also going to
get a spring k2x1, right?
Now are there any
other forces that
result from the motion of
that body in the springs?
Just spring forces now.
AUDIENCE: From that
body by itself?
J. KIM VANDIVER: Yeah,
that body by itself.
No.
But is that all
the spring forces?
No.
So now what if you
let body two move?
And now I'm going to give you
a little rubric, a little way
to go about this.
We start by assigning
our coordinates.
Then you specify positive x1, x1
dot, x2, x2 dot, one at a time.
And from that, you deduce
the direction of love
the forces, of the
resulting forces.
OK.
So if what we've done
there is consistent
with it, a positive value of
x1, spring one pulls back k1x1,
spring two pushes
back k1x1, then
that's the end of
spring forces due to x1.
So now just let's say, OK,
let x1 be 0 for a moment.
And now let there
be a positive x2.
Does that cause any
spring force on mass one?
What do you think?
AUDIENCE: We're going to
pull mass one [INAUDIBLE].
J. KIM VANDIVER: That
one-- a positive x2
puts tension in the spring and
it pulls it in that direction.
So now you're going
to get a k2x2.
Any other spring forces
caused by motion of two?
It's the only connecting spring.
So those are the spring
forces on mass one.
Now let's move on
to dashpot forces.
And you do exactly
the same thing.
Assume a positive
value of x1 dot.
What does it cause
in dashpot forces?
What's the first dashpot do
when you pull positive x1 dot
in that direction?
Resist or not?
AUDIENCE: Resist.
J. KIM VANDIVER:
Dashpots resist.
So it's going to be in the minus
direction and a value-- how
big?
AUDIENCE: c1 and [INAUDIBLE].
J. KIM VANDIVER: So now you
get dashpot forces, c1x1 dot.
And how about the c2 dashpot?
AUDIENCE: Same thing.
J. KIM VANDIVER:
Same thing. c2x1 dot.
OK.
And that's the only
dashpot forces caused
by a velocity of mass one.
So now let that be 0 and cause
velocity at the other places
and find out if
anything happens.
So now let x2 dot be positive.
What do we put on
free body diagram?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
J. KIM VANDIVER:
Going which direction?
Positive, and what value?
AUDIENCE: c2x2 dot.
J. KIM VANDIVER: All right.
And is our free body
diagram complete?
AUDIENCE: mg.
J. KIM VANDIVER: Oh, yeah.
And?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
J. KIM VANDIVER: Yeah, and?
AUDIENCE: The forces,
the external forces.
J. KIM VANDIVER:
Now it's complete.
All the forces in
the system, it's
constrained in this direction.
So we just know N equals mg.
There's no motion allowed,
so we get no equation
of motion in that direction.
We're going to get one equation
of motion for this mass
and one more equation of
motion for the second.
The number of
equation of motions
equal the number of
independent coordinates.
And we found two
We get two equations of motion.
So take this and write
down the equation of motion
for mass one.
Sort it out.
Yeah, Betsy?
AUDIENCE: So I'm really
confused by why c2 [INAUDIBLE]
in that direction,
because so [INAUDIBLE].
They oppose like the
springs that [? felt ?]
[? the closest ?] [INAUDIBLE].
J. KIM VANDIVER: OK.
So let's see if we
can do something here.
So, this is second mass.
This is the first mass.
Actually, here's the
wall and the first mass.
So x1 is in that direction.
If I pull that way, the
spring pulls back on the mass.
That's obvious to you, right?
And on the other side,
if this is mass one now
and you have a second
spring over here,
a second mass over here and
a spring in between them,
if you put a positive
motion of mass one,
this spring pushes back.
So that counts for the
minus direction of k2x1.
Then if the second mass moves
in that direction-- here,
you move it.
You're the second mass.
Is there tension in this?
Am I pulling back to
resist you are or not?
What is this spring
doing to my hand?
It's pulling that
way on it, k2x2.
AUDIENCE: OK.
J. KIM VANDIVER: OK.
So that's our free body diagram.
Write right out an equation
of motion for that system.
I'll give you a little reminder.
That's how you ought
to begin, right?
And if you're done, do the
same thing for the second mass
while the others are
working on the first one.
Draw a free body
diagram of mass two
and write down the
equation of motion.
AUDIENCE: Shouldn't
that be x2 dot?
J. KIM VANDIVER: Which one?
AUDIENCE: The bottom
left, c2x2 dot.
J. KIM VANDIVER: All
right, so let's build this.
I'm just going to
talk through it
rather than have you
help me build this.
The sum of the
external forces is
what all of the external forces
and only the external forces
should show up on that diagram.
The mass times
the accelerations,
the sum of the external forces--
so every arrow on that diagram
ought to appear over
here in the direction
of whichever this equation is.
So this is the
equation that has to do
with the motion of mass one.
And I look over here,
and I see, OK, I'm
just going to go top to
bottom, minus k1x1 minus k2x1--
and the minuses are
coming from the directions
of the arrows-- minus c1x1 dot.
And then I have plus k2x2
plus c2x2 dot plus F1.
AUDIENCE: And a minus c1x1.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
J. KIM VANDIVER: Did I miss one?
Oh, I missed the c-- I
missed this guy, right?
Minus c2x1 dot.
OK.
So the arrows tell me the signs.
And all the forces are there.
They just all add up
over here on this side.
And I've gone ahead
and drawn what
I think is the right
thing for mass two.
But you do the same system.
You go to mass two and
you say, OK, positive
deflection of mass one.
What is the spring
force that results?
Well, it pushes on it,
positive velocity of mass one.
This dashpot pushes on it.
Positive deflection of mass
two-- two springs push back.
Positive velocity of mass
two-- one dashpot resists.
And you have an external force.
And you could write
this one down.
You just add up
all those forces.
And now you have
a second equation,
m2x2 double dot equals
a you add it up.
OK.
So I want to do one other thing.
I'm going to ask you a question,
get you to raise your hand.
I want everybody to try
to raise their hands, OK?
Assume that I had written
out that second equation.
Actually, let me
take one more step.
Normally what we
would do is to rewrite
this in sort of a standard
form is to move all the motion
variables to one side and all
the actual exciting forces
to the other.
And so we'd say,
m1x1 double dot plus,
and then normally you put
in the x dot terms next.
So we have a c1 plus c2 x1
dot minus c2x2 dot plus-- now
I get my k terms-- k1 plus
k2 x1 minus k2x2 equals F1.
And that's kind of
standard form now.
I get a second equation
from the second one
that would look like that.
Now once you get it in
this sort of standard form,
can you remember how, if you've
even ever had linear algebra,
write this in matrix form?
AUDIENCE: It would
be [INAUDIBLE].
J. KIM VANDIVER:
So how many of you
feel comfortable that you could
just sit down and write this
out in matrix form?
Go on.
And how many of you think it
might be a bit of a challenge?
OK.
How many of you would
like me to show you
what it looks like in matrix
form and give you the answer?
So most of you.
OK, I'll take the
time to do that.
Actually, did I
write it out already?
Ooh, look at that.
Bing!
Ding, ding, ding!
All you need to know in
this course about vectors
and matrices is how to multiply
a vector times a matrix.
So here's an
acceleration vector.
Here's the mass matrix.
And you take these two
elements, my two fingers here,
and multiplying by those--
you go like this to that.
So x1 double dot times m1 double
dot gives you this term, right?
And you get no m2x2 double
dot, because there's
a 0 in the matrix in
that second position.
So you get no x2
double dot term.
And that's correct.
Same thing with the--
here's the x2, x1.
Here's this damping matrix.
This is the stiffness matrix.
And so if you just
did these multiplies,
you'd get back two equations,
the ones we just derived.
So you need to know how
to do this kind of thing
because we write that
h equals I omega.
And our omega has three
components, omega x, omega y,
and omega z.
And you need to be able
to do that manipulation.
All right, we've got a
little bit of time left.
I wanted to do one
little exercise that
had to do more with
this sort of thing,
to kind of reinforce a
bit what we did yesterday.
And that would be-- so any
final questions about this?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So setting
that up looks OK.
But solving it.
J. KIM VANDIVER: Oh, solving it?
I used to teach-- I
taught for about 20 years
a course called
Mechanical Vibration.
I just don't have time
to teach it anymore.
And that's what you do in there.
Oh, in 803 you do
a little bit of it.
So this system has two
degrees of freedom.
It has two natural frequencies,
two mode shapes to go with it.
So the system vibrates.
And it's not real
hard to solve, but you
would assume for
initially, if you
want to know
natural frequencies,
you set the forces to 0.
You set the damping
to 0 initially.
And you just assume a
solution of the form
that x1 of t and x2 of t equals
some unknown constants, cosine
omega t.
Just plug it in.
You just plug that in.
You'll end up with an
algebraic equation.
And the algebraic equation
actually has eigenvalues.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
J. KIM VANDIVER: And you
find the two eigenvalues,
and they're the two
natural frequencies.
All right.
I want to do something
with angular stuff.
So here's my system
that we were playing
with at the beginning of class.
And in this form, it's
nice and balanced.
So this is just to
reinforce a couple things
that I was just beginning
to teach you yesterday.
This is a rigid body.
It's rotating.
I attach to it a rotating frame.
At a in the x
direction is y and z.
So y's into the board.
And that frame rotates
with my system.
And the rotation rate
of this system is omega,
and it's k in the
rotating system, which
happens to line up with big
K with the stationary system.
But this is my omega vector.
Here is 0, 0 omega.
This is the z component
of the rotation.
Now, let's first
start with this.
What is P1, [? an 0, ?]
the linear momentum
of that mass in the system?
And you've done this
probably a lot of times.
So what direction's it in?
Momentum is mv, right?
So what's the
velocity of the mass?
AUDIENCE: It's rotating.
J. KIM VANDIVER: It's caused
by rotation and only rotation.
AUDIENCE: So it could be
the [? c hat ?] direction.
[INAUDIBLE].
J. KIM VANDIVER: No, P,
just P. Linear momentum.
AUDIENCE: That P itself--
linear because it's [INAUDIBLE].
J. KIM VANDIVER: And it's
got to [? an 0, ?] right?
I mean, reference
to the 0 frame.
But it can use unit
vectors in the A frame.
So what's v1?
AUDIENCE: j hat.
J. KIM VANDIVER: j
hat, and how big?
AUDIENCE: Omega.
J. KIM VANDIVER: I hear
an omega times what?
So this is system-- I'm
going to call this position,
this is x1z1.
This coordinate is x1z1.
So if I give you
that information,
what's the velocity
of that point?
AUDIENCE: Omega x.
AUDIENCE: x.
J. KIM VANDIVER: Omega x1--
AUDIENCE: Oh, j hat.
J. KIM VANDIVER: j hat.
It's into the board, the way
it's spinning into the board.
Yeah, ought to be
in the j direction.
Yeah, it ought to be
an r omega, and it
has an m associated with it.
What's P2?
AUDIENCE: In the [INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: Negative [INAUDIBLE].
J. KIM VANDIVER: It's coming
out of the board at you.
AUDIENCE: Right.
Negative m2 omega xj.
J. KIM VANDIVER: Right?
OK.
And those little j's-- the
j hats are in the rotating
coordinate system
where I want them.
So what's H1?
It's r1 with respect to what?
So you can't do angular
momentum without picking a--?
You've got to pick the point.
So this is why we choose the
coordinates on the reference
frame that we're going to use
to give us some information
that we want.
I want to know the
torques about this point.
So I'm going to put my A here.
I could have put it any place,
as long as the axis of rotation
passed through it.
So this one is r1 with
respect to A cross P1.
So what is r1 in this system?
AUDIENCE: x1.
J. KIM VANDIVER: x1i--
AUDIENCE: Plus z--
J. KIM VANDIVER: 1k
cross with m1 omega x1 j.
All right?
Let's work that one out.
So we have an i times a j.
And so I get an m1x1
squared omega k.
And then I do this
term times that.
I get a k cross j minus i.
And I get m1x1z1 omega i hat.
All right.
Technically this is my
little h, this is little h2.
And if I let m1 equal m2 here,
my total h for this system--
AUDIENCE: Isn't that just--
J. KIM VANDIVER: Pardon?
AUDIENCE: This is [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: The second minus--
AUDIENCE: The second
minus is still h1.
J. KIM VANDIVER: Oh,
whoops, how'd I do that?
Yeah, I hadn't
moved on to h2 yet.
Sorry about that.
This is still h1.
OK.
And it's that.
So what's h2?
How's it differ?
Just kind of look here.
It only differs in one respect.
AUDIENCE: Negative sign?
J. KIM VANDIVER: Yeah, you get
a minus-- a negative x here
when you go to carry
out the multiplication.
So now the i cross
j term gives you a--
AUDIENCE: But isn't the P2
also have a negative under it.
J. KIM VANDIVER: Yeah,
you're absolutely right.
So you get-- you had
to put a minus x here.
And you have to
multiply by this one.
So the i, j term, you have
a minus times a minus.
i times j is a positive k.
You end up with m2x1 squared
omega k, the same direction
of each component.
Then what happens here?
AUDIENCE: Comes from
a minus [INAUDIBLE].
J. KIM VANDIVER: OK.
And so the second term, the i
term, is opposite direction.
And if m1 equals m2 and you
added these two together,
what happened to
those last two terms?
They cancel, right?
[LAUGHTER]
OK, so if this is true,
the sum of these two,
H, with respect to A, is
just 2mx1 squared omega k.
All right.
So if you took-- in
the first system,
if these two weren't equal
and they didn't cancel out,
if you go through
here and take dh dt,
you take the time
derivative of these terms,
then you get an omega dot k.
And over here you get
an omega dot term.
And then you get a
di dt term, all that.
But you will end up
with values of dh dt
that are not in the k direction.
You agree?
For sure.
And those are associated
with the real torques
in the system that happen.
When this is true, that
difficult term out here
cancels out.
And you're left only
with the k term.
And when you take this time
derivative, you only get dh dt.
You get a theta
dot or omega dot.
And that says the torque
is in what direction when
you get just this for h?
What is the direction of dh dt?
It's still in k.
So the torque is
aligned with the spin.
h is aligned with the spin.
They're all aligned.
And the system is actually
beautifully balanced.
You don't feel any torques
around where you're holding it
down here at A. But if I took
one of these off, kind of back
to that one arm system,
it's terribly unbalanced.
So the moral of
the story here is
if I don't want to have
these unwanted torques,
what can you say
about the desired mass
distribution in the system?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
J. KIM VANDIVER: I hear
a vote for symmetry.
And that's the general rule.
If your masses are
distributed symmetrically
about the axis of spin,
no off axis torques.
AUDIENCE: And it's
[INAUDIBLE] mass [INAUDIBLE].
J. KIM VANDIVER:
Yeah, it's symmetric.
Symmetry means they better
be the same size too,
not just in the same place.
If one's twice as big
as the other, no go.
If I put a second mass
on one of those arms,
the system is back
to being unbalanced.
So any time this H vector,
the total H of the system,
is not lined up with
the spin, the system
has an asymmetry in it.
And the system will require
additional torques just
to hold it in place
when it's spinning.
So when you have these
additional torques that
come from being a
symmetric, the system
is said to be
dynamically imbalanced.
So if you pick up a stone, a
big stone, in your car wheel
or block hunk of mud or ice
that's frozen on the rim,
you're going down the
road, what's it feel like?
You ever had an unbalanced
tire on your car?
Boy, where have you guys lived?
An unbalanced tire on a car,
you're going down the road.
You know?
Right?
That's what this is all about.
You have a case of imbalance.
How are we doing on time?
A couple more minutes.
So imbalance comes from
having angular momentum that's
not pointed in same direction
as-- angular momentum not
pointed in the same direction
as the angle of spin
is evidence of unbalance.
And you can calculate how bad
the unbalance is by doing dh dt
and actually finding out how
much torque is being applied
to the system that ordinarily
the bearings wouldn't
have to resist.
But this thing has
overturning torques
that are trying to make it
wobble back and forth on you.
So one last exercise,
which is actually
a quite important point.
If I moved A up here right
on the line between these two
things-- so this is A. And
now this is x, and this is z.
The coordinates of
this point become what?
x1 and--
AUDIENCE: 0.
J. KIM VANDIVER: 0.
And all these
equations still apply.
So if I just move my coordinate
system so the x's are the same,
z's go to 0.
What do you end
up with for terms?
What happens to this thing?
That goes to 0.
It goes away.
And you only get this term, and
so by simply moving A to here,
my angular momentum vector
now lines up with the spin.
Kind of weird.
Does the imbalance still exist?
Will your car still be
doing this down the road
just because you
chose to look at it
from a different point of view?
Yeah.
I mean, the car's still unhappy.
So there's kind of
inconsistency here, sort of.
What's the problem?
Or maybe not a
problem, but you choose
to put A when you're
computing angular momentum.
You can choose where you
put this point to give you
the information you're after.
And in this case, if I
were designing this system
and I wanted to know the bending
moment in these bars sticking
down here, I put A
here because it'll
give you the torques with
respect to this point.
These torques down
here still exist.
If you put your point at which
you compute angular momentum up
here, you won't be
able to find them.
You can't compute it because
you've reduced the moment
arm to 0, this moment arm, and
you just won't get that torque.
OK.
All right, I've run out of time.
But there'll be more
on this subject.